e
time being uh 9:30 I'd like to uh open
up our long range Capital planning and
utilization committee um
Chris are we okay with the Quorum or we
need to wait oh okay we will uh we will
stay in recess for a couple minutes here
us
that move I came late to the first
meeting
so thank you thank you Sanders for
attending I give you a moment to uh get
your packet
so I would like to uh open long range
Capital planning utilization committee
meeting um and I would like to start
with the acceptance of the minutes of
June 10th so moved motion made second
seconded um any discussion I will
abstain because I was not at the last
meeting all right thank you rep clud
here uh if you're in favor of the motion
to accept the minutes of June 10th 2024
signified by saying I I any opposed one
exension
okay we have no old business we will
move to uh new business disposal highway
or or Turnpike funds and real estate
first item is
2431 Department of Transportation author
authorization to sell approximately five
acres stayed on Norths side in the town
of Troy and with that sir please
introduce yourself and present item 31
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Steve leonti I am
the legislative liaison and um senior
hearings examiner at the Department of
Transportation um today the department
requests authorization to sell
1.50 Acres of state owned land located
on the northeast side of manad street in
the town of Troy department will enter
into a listing agreement for the term of
one year with HKS
Associates uh with the listing price of
$52,500 plus the administrative fee of
$1,100 uh and it will be um HKS if
they're successful in the sale will'll
be given a
6% uh sales
commission um the um the subject
property is identified in the town of
Troy tax records as as tax map 12 lot
15b it was purchased on December 6 2004
from Lakeville Shores Incorporated for
29,000 for the Troy bypass project which
was later dissolved in August of
2016 uh the sale will be subject to the
following conditions the grantee will be
responsible to get any local and state
approvals uh and the sale will be um
subject
to um a restriction will be placed on
the property um in the event of a sale
which will require the purchaser to
coordinate with uh DHR to if they do any
kind of subsurface investig ation
because of the archaeological
sensitivity of the
property um we received a marketing
analysis from four different realtors
and we determined that HKS
Associates uh was based on their
marketing analysis and what they gave
for their estimate of a value we uh it
was closest to the state's appraisal
which was was done by a certified
license certified General appraiser in
the state and we determine HKS was a
successful
bidder thank you
none moved by Lang seconded by Pearl um
if you're in favor of item
031 signify by saying I I any opposed
motion carries Mr lante would you move
to item 32 please yes thank you Mr
chairman uh Department requests
authorization to
sell
3,350 square fet or
077 acres of state-owned land located on
the northeasterly side of Route 11 in
Guilford um also known as um south of of
belnap Point
Road uh the sale will be direct to the
abutter Richard zagan in the amount of
$61,500 plus an administrative fee of
$1,100 the state-owned parcel was
acquired from the estate of Alfred V
Lincoln by quick claim deed as part of a
larger partial parcel in
1959 for the realignment and
construction of Route 11 in Guilford uh
the department um this the sales
conditions will be required to have a
survey done uh the grante uh will be
also responsible for obtaining all local
and state approvals and due to the
proximity of the uh with the Lincoln
municipal airport the grantee will Al
the grantee will be notified of any FAA
required notices should they do any kind
of construction uh a a staff appraiser
appraise the property as contributory
value just because of its shape and
location it won't be have it won't have
$1,400 um
yeah that's $61,500 and per statute the
town of Guilford will be offered the
property as well as in New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority but they're
likely not to have any
interest thank you any further
questions seeing none appr motion motion
made by Lang second second by Mills um
if you're in favor of uh item number
32 um would you signify by saying I hi
if you're opposed
nay uh passes unanimously thank you Mr
lonte can we go to item
33 thank you Mr chairman Department
requests approval to dispose of a parcel
of state-owned land consisting of
35.58 Acres located on the southerly
side of Manan Street in the town of Troy
um it's in proximity to the previous
sale as identified or the item number
24-31
one um the department will enter into a
listing agreement a one-year listing
agreement with
HKS uh the listing price will be
45,000 and they will assess an $1100
administrative fee
$45,000 and they will assess an $1,100
administrative fee uh the department is
um okay uh the parcel was acquired on
December 6 2004 from Lake Shores Inc for
82,000 uh also for the Troy bypass
project which again was dissolved on
August 24th
2016 um the parcel is encumbered by a
utility easement to Public Service of
New Hampshire uh which is approximately
um 4.72 3 acres on the easterly side of
the p uh parcel after a departmental
review it was determined that with
Surplus the part the par the parcel will
be sold with the following conditions uh
a survey will be required and uh the
survey will prepare a perimeter boundary
line plan uh it will also be sold with
the same restrictions as was put on item
031 um due to the archaeological
sensitivity of the area um again there
were five realtors
that um submitted marketing analysis for
this parcel and
HKS again based on their analysis based
on their location we determined that
they were probably best to market the
property uh they will be given a 6%
commission should they be
successful again uh the state took a
look at this parcel
um and initially thought it was uh
appraised a value a a value of
114,000 but after looking at HKS
analysis we thought we could probably go
145,000 questions from Mr lante on this
item yes send
L I'm looking at your appraisals so five
appraisals here and the states is way
low compared to everybody else uh the
closest one is a the next highest bid is
56,000 by the people you're selecting
with the high in a 355 range and yet
we're selling for
145 but there a reason we're so low
compared to what even the estimates of
the commercial Realtors are well again
we we we actually went up from our
initial appraisal um based on again this
is reviewed by a licensed certified
General appraiser many of the um real
estate agencies that put in
analysis they're not doing that a a a
certifi a CGI is going to go in and
they're going to do further analysis and
that's the number they came up with when
he reviewed
the uh when he reviewed
hk's
um hk's marketing
analysis he had determined that okay it
could come up off uh off 114 but he
thought the number was
145,000 now we can go up from that uh
certainly but um that's what we thought
a reasonable number that would Fetch and
with in light of the fact that
somebody's going to have to come in if
they want to do any type of development
they have to coordinate with DHR just
sensitivity Senator satisfied with that
Mo move on the item move to approve
sorry um motion by Lang SE by Pearl to
approve item uh 02 uh
033 if you're in favor of the motion
signified by saying I I if you're oppose
nay motion carries
unanimously Lon item uh
34 please thank you Mr chairman um I'll
first point out that there was a hand
out given for this item and also for
035 uh just to help explain it uh
because what we're doing is we're sell
we're selling a section of the layout of
the Conway bypass that's made up of uh I
believe it's seven different parcels and
uh we're F we're selling that directly
to uh the abutter Shan and Caitlyn
Baldwin for 235,000
um which they've already paid the uh
administrative fee of 1100 when they put
in the initial request so what I've done
is I've provided that handout because as
I went through the
description of looking at the
description of the various Parcels I it
was difficult to kind of follow along
because this Corridor is made up of bits
and pieces of larger Parcels so as you
look at it you can see that first we
look at parcel 87 and as I looked at
this description it it is a little
misleading so in this case this was done
in this was this was completed back in
2006 and what happened was or 2006 and
and what happened was the owner at the
time was interested in another parcel uh
a section of of par
88 and what was worked out and
negotiated was a land slap plus and in
this case actually what happened is the
state swapped 1.72 Acres that was worth
11,000 in return the state credited
5,000 which was the value as determined
of the section of parcel
87 that the state was receiving and the
um owner at the time Mr Charles gave the
state
$6,000 so the two values the value was
$11,000 the state
provided um property and credit and in
return We also got
$6,000 um parcel 88 as you see basically
it
it is um a smaller section consists
inside the corridor that's now part of
the subject property and the remaining
section was purchased by the state and
then previously conveyed to
um I believe Mr Baldwin or his
predecessor and interest and that's the
same for 89 90 as you look up at
91 um the the sale
kind of shoots out because there were
these um uneconomic remnants that the
state had to buy because basically it
was it was um bisecting them from the
larger parcel and then you have parcel
92 and parcel 94 that makes up the
um that makes up the subject parcel that
is being
conveyed uh again the conditions of the
sale will require the uh grantee to
commission a licens land surveyor to do
a boundary line uh survey uh buyers
responsible for obtaining all state and
local approvals and um the property also
will be conveyed to uh conveyed subject
to a trail easement that will be uh held
by uh
dncr so uh we uh staff appraiser took a
look at that took a look at the property
and determined that it had a value of
lonte motion um made by Lang second by
Mills to approve item
034 if you're in favor of that motion
you signify by saying I I I if you
oppose nay motion carries unanimously
uh before you move to the next item sir
item
35 um a qu I don't believe you have any
answer to this but I'm just going to ask
U Chris if you could ask the department
so we're we're getting to a point that
we're able to sell off many of these
Parcels from the Conway
bypass um is anyone keeping a running T
of how when these Parcels are sold and
what the balance is and
um because I if I remember it's going to
be a tremendous drain on on our state
paying this back the answer to that is
yes the department has kept a running
total and I believe and Steve if you can
correct me the Department's paid what
was owed back to the federal government
so they they've paid what was owed the
money that they get for these sales goes
back to replenish what they use to pay
that thank you appreciate
that all right we will move on to item
35 please
item 35 is um similar
to uh item 34 in that where we're
selling a larger parcel that's made up
of um bits and pieces of other Parcels
again this uh parcel is a total of 32.2
three acres um which lies in between
um Eaton Road and Stark Road in the town
of Conway uh the sale will be directly
to James and Jean Drummond for
$175,000 and the uh $1,100
administrative fee uh the subject
property is made up of six Parcels which
divide uh divides the land now owned by
the Drummonds and um so Drummond own a
larger parcel the corridor basically
bisects that in half they own the the
parcels on either side so um we're
selling these Parcels parcel 77 is a
small parcel as you can see on the
handout parcel 80 uh again has um parcel
80 and and
79 um we bought purchased from the
kennet
property partiel
83 and as you see I'll point out parcel
85 is pretty apparent on the handout but
parcel 84 I just point out that it's
pieces so the um the buyer again in this
case the buyer will uh as a condition of
sale be required to commission a
licensed land surveyor to do a perimeter
uh boundary line survey uh the buyer
responsible for obtaining all uh uh any
and all state and local approvals
um and again this property will also be
sold subject to the trail eement that uh
will be held by
dncr again this was looked at by a
certified General appraiser and
157 U
$175,000 was was uh determined to be the
value thank you sir
questions
approve motion by Lang second by Pearl
to approve uh the sale of item
35 you have a question
please okay sounds good if you're if
you're in favor of that motion you'll
signify by saying I I and oppose nay
motion
carries um I will recognize
R question uh thank you Mr chairman it's
a general question you've gone through a
lot of these and we've gone through them
in the past when you say uh regist land
surveyor is going to provide a a plot or
whatever do they also set in the corners
they also doing putting a is it part of
the uh requirement to to put the
boundary markers in so that that'll
depend on the sale um we we will do that
if there is a need for it um and that's
usually a determination that's made by
our uh chief of mapping and Survey if he
he sees there's value like we just sold
a piece in entrum and markers were put
in to establish
the uh conservation easement that was
that property was being sold under uh we
earlier this year we sold a property up
in Conway that had a rail Corridor going
through it markers were put on either
corner to to establish where that rail
Corridor was so it all depends but if
it's a larger parcel out in the middle
it it may not require we may not make
that as a condition further question uh
yes thank you
um sometimes it's really confusing of
what who owns what out there especially
when you're switching stuff around like
this I think it really ought to be
considered to be putting these in so
there's no question in the future that's
just a comment okay thank you thank we
look
at seeing no further question we will
move to item 029 PR environmental
service requesting authorization weeks
Crossing Dam in Warren New
welcome to uh Public Works and please
please thank you chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Corey Clark I'm the chief engineer at
the dam Bureau at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
in this request nhcs is seeking the
transfer ownership of weeks Crossing Dam
from the state of New Hampshire to the
town of
Warren the backstory on this is uh July
1st of 2017 week's Crossing Dam failed
during a flooding event resulting from a
significant thunderstorm in the baker
River Valley this failure caused gou
Hill Road which is located immediately
Downstream of the dam to be over topped
and
failed because of the significant value
that week's Crossing Pond provided to
the community the town of waren
in the form of recreation but also more
importantly in the form of fire
suppression the town seek assistance to
try to rebuild the dam through fishing
game who was at the time the owner of
that structure ultimately it was agreed
upon by the town Dees and fishing game
because Dees is responsible for the uh
repair and operation of Maintenance of
fishing game owned structures that the
state would rebuild the dam and the town
would take over ownership once the dam
was
rebuilt so NH s worked with uh FEMA at
the time and was able to secure 75%
funding for that reconstruction and so
nhds undertook the Reconstruction using
Force account labor that reconstruction
of weeks Crossing dam was completed in
2021 after securing the necessary
easements through fish from fishing game
along with a adjacent Property Owners
the footprint of the dam had to be
offset a little bit moved upst stream
from where it was located prior because
of the location of goldhill
Road and during the Warren town meeting
in March of 2023 the town voted to take
over ownership and maintenance of the
dam and so nhcs has been working since
that time with FEMA to make sure that
they have all the requirements that they
need to secure the funding reimbursement
and we are pretty close to finalizing
that documentation to transfer the
funding from that reconstruction to
nhcs so the transfer of this Dam will be
one small step in reducing the number of
dams that the state of New Hampshire
currently owns Which is a goal of HDs as
the risk associated with Dam ownership
continues to increase and Dam become
more of a financial burden on the state
of New Hampshire this item was presented
to the New Hampshire Council on
resources and development in May 11th
2023 and was approved at that
Clark motion by Lang
seconded uh by Pearl to move item for
the U transfer of property item number
29 if you're in favor of that motion
you'll signify by saying I I I those
oppos nay motion carries um please make
all towns aware that we're willing to
turn dams over to maybe in one of your
thank we will uh move to item uh 3 our
last uh item here Department of
administration
of services approval to sell on behalf
of State of New Hampshire City of
Claremont for
700,000 uh fees .25 acres Land South
please there we go good morning Mr
chairman honorable committee members uh
my name is Jared Nyland I'm the real
property asset manager with the
Department of administrative Services uh
the department uh proposes to sell on
behalf of the State of New Hampshire to
the City of Claremont uh the Claremont
the manad mill Building located at 17
Water Street in Claremont along with the
quarter acre or so of land that it sits
upon um for the selling price of
$700,000 which includes the $1,100
administrative fee uh required by RSA
440 comma
3A
um the building uh is a four-story
office building consisting of 30 over
32,000 uh square square feet of gross
building area and over 21,000 square
feet of usable interior office space um
this is a historic Mill building it was
originally constructed in 1840 the state
acquired it in
1981 uh for little or almost no
considerate $1 or no consideration
depending on your source of
information um we then proceeded to
invest uh approximately $1.6 million in
renovating it and then continue to use
it as an office building as a State
Office Building uh until earlier this
year um the department identified it
some time ago as a building that had uh
increasing maintenance costs uh regular
maintenance costs time and time again um
a few years ago the decision was made
the termination was made that we would
like to uh dispose of it uh due to the
mounting costs of of continuing to own
it um and then we proceeded to wait
until this year uh when the Last Tenant
agency uh DHHS uh finally vacated uh so
now the building is vacant and um when
we began the disposal process we had we
received interest from the New Hampshire
Housing Finance New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority um they took a look at
the building toured it uh but then uh
contacted us and decided they were let
us know that they had decided they were
not interested uh we then proceeded to
speak with the City of Claremont uh they
had previously expressed interest in
acquiring the building uh and we arrived
at a price of
$700,000 um we don't have any we haven't
negotiated any conditions of sale I
anticipate that the city will want to do
a phase one environmental site
assessment that's probably about it um
and
uh oh and cord we received cord
recommended the proposed disposal by
sale at its meeting in
August thank you m questions represent
cluder uh yeah okay well I want time I'd
like to make the motion to approve if
it's sure yeah I'm thank you Mr
chairman morning thanks for coming so so
where did all the tenants that were in
this building where did they relocate
too did we build a new facility
there um I can't I do not know the
answer to that to the entire answer to
that question so the tenants were
primarily state agencies so one by one
they have found other digs um whether by
Le or building I don't know uh in
individual cases DHHS well I keep
looking over it Karen I know she knows
the answer to these questions um but
yeah I I I believe DHHS moved into a new
nearby did you have something to add and
I Pro I apologize for my formality by
just calling you Karen so it's okay
Karen rcky director of plant and
property with the de Department of
administrative Services um just to
follow up on on Jared's comment ments
which are all true um the DMV was in
there at one point as well as um
probation parole office for the
Department of Corrections and over time
they've decided that this building is
not really ideal for their operations
and have moved to other locations um
DHHS recently found a lease property um
and they moved out in um the end of June
of of this current year so that's kind
of thank for that any further
questions uh represent cluder recognized
for a motion yes I moved tox that we
24-30 motion made and seconded uh if
you're in favor of that motion you'll
signify by saying I I any opposed seeing
none motion carries unanimously thank
you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um Chris do you want to um speak to the
informational item
036 say 036 is just a report from cord
on um their last meeting where they in
may excuse me not their last meeting the
meeting from May 9th um we get these
periodically to include as informational
items for the committee agencies will
also include cord minutes or information
as they make recommendations to disos of
property what you may see from these is
um potentially items that are going to
come forward at a later time or that may
be before you
today thank you um day to the next
meeting uh we just finished our our
previous um Capital meeting and I've
offered November 12th a Tuesday as our
uh as our designated day if you want to
check schedules get back to us uh
starting at
9:30 November 12th I'm not sure whether
I can have a dental appointment but I
I think I'm okay
okay all right with that accept a motion
to uh adjourn so mov if you're in favor
of that motion signified by saying I I
we are closed for
time